on a trop vendée c'est trop cool voilà
venez n'hésitez pas à défaut coop à vous
couper nos enfants vous famille heureuse
il est interdit de ram et les chats
parce que je suis allergique aux chats
tout le chat le chat machine bicarbonate
hamas a mis sous caso enfin bon les
dream tient coi les meilleurs voilà
voilà on est arrivé on se prépare
hello bye
il règne ici un silence de mort car
thibault a offert à ml 2 c
ouais 108 ap du départ c'est bien sa
gamme aujourd'hui nous allons découvrir
les dernières tendances de la télévision
à travers le mythe comme le mipcom c'est
plus qu'on marche audiovisuels destinés
aux professionnels ça lieu deux fois par
an et là il nous présente un petit peu
les nouveautés les intervenants ça va
être passionnant j'espère
[Musique]
alors mais ces trois variables ce genre
c'est la première chose que j'ai prise
comme un arbre en sortant de son produit
en sortant de la team manager dit le
maire de végétaux sont unis 8 7 5
minutes après mais très luxueux alors
regardez les ils ont l'hérault également
au taquet regarder les puissants gogh et
son beau c'est parti et que prêcher
n'était prêt chalet oui mais plus
impressionné par son tee shirt
oui c'est trop payé
ces végétaux mais j'ai tort on est
d'accord avec me l'algérie foot en garde
mais ouais commencé que la télé l'amour
c'est beau jour tant que sa marina
bellot rennais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah
[Musique]
normalement demain c'est mon jour de
repos parce que j'ai 18h34 mp xxl et
après bien sûr j'ai pas mon badge merci
monsieur merci
[Musique]